this is your reminder that the BBC has
yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
problem here's the thing if you want to
move forward you got to know your
history
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there folks uh I feel like doing
another Doctor Who list and this one uh
is going to be in two parts I'm going to
do a top 10 and a bottom 10 and I'm
going to do it on Doctor Who
historicals about that this is actually
going to be a top 11 because I realized
while I was editing I completely forgot
an episode that absolutely needs to be
on this list and I didn't feel like
dropping any of the ones I'd already
shot sections for so have fun guessing
which one I had to add in I debated uh
possibly doing it as uh the entire uh of
all the modern era because I still
haven't seen all of classic I'm working
on it um the all the modern era
historicals uh except that there's well
there's anywhere from 36 to 41 of them
depending on what you feel counts as a
historical and that that that's a bit
longer than I want to commit to a single
video at least right now I'm I'm trying
to adjust my workload and get some stuff
that I've been working on for ages
finished because some stuff's really
been waiting to get finished so instead
we're doing this which means that if
everything goes as planned next month
you'll get the bottom 10 um but for
right now let's uh talk about Doctor Who
historicals meaning an episode of Doctor
Who set in the past now as I said how
many historicals there are in the modern
era kind of depends on what you feel
counts what I basically went by is kind
of gut feeling like there are episodes
that only have certain parts take place
in the past like say can you hear me or
technically even Church on Ruby Road but
I didn't want to be that allinclusive so
basically the metric I used was you know
what if somebody saw this on a list of
historicals would they go wait a oh
right or would they just go yeah no no
so if if it if in my mind it was likely
to make somebody go oh yeah that is a
historical isn't it then I'm not
considering it and yes that's a Loosey
Goosey metric welcome to the channel
before we get into the list proper it's
probably worth noting I tend to not be
the big biggest fan of the historicals
um that's not to say I blanketly always
dislike them I'm obviously going to have
some things to praise in what's going to
be coming up but um they have a tendency
to cause Dr R to indulge in some of its
habits that I don't really enjoy a big
one that tends to be connected to
historicals is the over grandis of
certain specific historical figures
which often just annoys me as a way to
view history I it's the great man view
of history of like these are the
important people which is I just don't
think is
uh a great way to standardize how we we
view history especially when we don't
have to in the way that we depict it
like you could be taking a broader look
you could be dealing with ordinary
people instead of oh no look no that
okay Churchill all right and it's
usually over a grandis and and all this
kind of stuff that bugs me but that is
probably not something that's going to
be on too much display in this because
these are the ones I like but it is
worth caveat this is not my favorite
type of Doctor Who not because I'm
against historicals but because the
sorts of things that tend to come out of
historicals lean into aspects of Doctor
Who that can bug me but with that
understanding which might help you uh
come to a better grasp of why certain
things did or didn't make this top 10
list I don't know we'll see but let's
get to
it number
11 robot of
Sherwood oh boy this I probably just
lost a bunch of people immediately with
that choice um because the the the thing
is robot of Sherwood is divisive it is
one of the campier episodes to be frank
about it and I often don't like Dr Hood
be camping but there's something about
the rolicking adventure nature of doing
a Robin Hood story of having the doctor
himself be skeptical about how this
could even be the case cuz as far as the
doctor is concerned robinhood's folklore
what are you even doing here here the
balance of tone and setting and also
just kind of being a sucker for Robin
Hood as a character and as an archetype
yeah this this kind of this kind of just
hit me in a happy place especially with
the banter this episode has some
fantastic banter between the doctor and
claraa the doctor and Robin it's just
great it's it's so so fun it is not a
competition about who can die slower it
definitely would be me though wouldn't
it historically accurate well no not
really again was Robin Hood even real
good chance not but I I just have a lot
of fun with this and a bunch of people
have already now clicked off I'm sure
because this made my top
10 I I just got to be honest I like this
[Music]
one number
hide now this one I can a little bit
more legitimately defend now people
might not always I I don't think it's
necessarily A oh yeah level of
historical but I don't think the
historical aspects are the first thing
that people think of when they think of
this episode if they think of it at all
I feel like this is a bit of an
underrated episode in general and it's
not as appreciated as it should be but I
really love the anachronistic nature of
like ghost hunting and and spiritualism
and ooh what what might we find out
about the other side for the era that
it's set in and sort of the nature of
the characters these amateur Ghost
Hunters just trying to figure out what's
what with the doctor and clar stumbling
into this whole situation it's
atmospheric and I think it captures not
just you know the concept of ghost
hunting but a very specific era and
level of interest in that from the time
period in which it's set and I think it
pulls it off really well and I still
like the tail end Twist on this thing
another thing that I think gets
underappreciated
[Music]
number
nine Nicola Tesla's night of Terror this
is one I didn't properly appreciate on
first viewing and I'll also mention at
this point I probably don't enjoy this
much as an episode as much as I do the
previous two however while I don't have
a rigid grading system or anything I am
sort of taking depictions of the history
into account with these rankings this
isn't just a ranking of what I
personally enjoy the most because in
that case robot of Sherwood would have
actually been higher than number 11 but
realizing how historically inaccurate It
Well by its nature it definitely is that
had to go on the lower end but it's
still definitely a historical here I
mean there's still the natural um
inaccuracies about just yeah there
weren't aliens with Nicola Tesla but the
examination of who he was what he did
the kind of environment he was working
in and the struggles he had but also
honestly giving a fairer shake to Edison
than I was expecting like Edison is very
easy to make a villain if you're talking
about Tesla and not wrongly either guy
was a jerk but it was a lot fairer to
him than I expected I was expecting a
straw man version of Edison but despite
all the things about him that he you
know just he buys brilliant people and
and owns the things that they create yes
he did some of his own invention but a
lot of it is just people who work for
him May thing and now it's his and I
enjoy the the critique and the analysis
of that that happens it's not deep but
it's like yeah no this is a problem but
it doesn't turn him into a cartoon
character he clearly cares when his
employees are in danger when people are
going to be hurt this matters to him
he's not callous so again fair or shake
to even a antagonistic character all
those men work for me they had families
I had dinner with this guy and his wife
last week I have to tell her in General
I on rewatch I've actually come to
appreciate this episode more overall
than I did on first viewing but I like
it even more for feeling like it gave
more depth not only to Tesla in a way
that wasn't purely a grand ising there's
a little bit of that it's by its nature
but not quite as much as I would have
expected but also just being fairer to
the other guy yeah yeah this this one
this episode's been slowly climbing in
my estimation in
general number
eight Cold War this is another one that
is booed by capturing the mood of a time
because by pure enjoyment this this
still be on theist but it would be lower
than this but the capturing of that
tension of that
look we're trying to to survive you're
trying to survive but you could kill us
and we could kill you and if we don't
figure this out we're all gonna
die that's the Cold War that's the Cold
War in a nutshell that horrible feeling
of if we try and be nice to you are you
just going to take advantage and wipe us
out that paranoia that tension it's
baked into this episode and is very
reflective of the time it is set in and
it's also got a fantastic supporting cat
David Warner big bonus points right
there and I kind of like the ice
Warriors like they're they're they're
absurd and ridiculous especially if you
watch classic they're very easy to laugh
at but I do just kind of like them and I
think using an ice warrior in this
setting to exemplify that kind of
tension that sort of innate look we
don't have to be at odds but we also
don't seem to know how to be okay with
each other and using that as an alien on
a submarine story as a filter for the
overall tension of the Cold War yeah
this thing does some interesting
[Music]
stuff number
seven the fires of
Pompei this one uh is honestly just
great character work is a big part of
this I mean I do like the historical
setting uh overall I do just kind of
enjoy that but you know between Peter
Capaldi and and his characters family
being a fantastic Supporting Cast Donna
getting some great character moments and
especially in her connection with David
Tennant's 10th Doctor there's some
really amazing character work
here and the main reason it's not higher
is because the things that I truly love
about it are not the historical stuff
the historical stuff is good but this a
little bit like robots of Sherwood is
more an episode I really like that
happens to be a historical as opposed to
something that really does a lot with
the historical setting I mean this does
some stuff for sure it really Embraces
the setting and the tone and the feel um
of that era and that sense of like oh
things are moving forward such such
progress an exciting time and then
everything comes crashing down in the
absolute worst possible way it does
capture all that so it's not doing
nothing with it with it setting but what
I'm mainly here for is the character
focus
and yeah this does that amazingly and
the historical stuff is pretty
good number
six the girl in the fireplace this is
another one where the character work is
what puts it higher than uh if I was
grading strictly on the historical level
because since we are only really seeing
the historical aspect through uh the
interactions that the doctor has with
renette we aren't actually dwelling in
the historical space the way that is
more typical for a doctor who historical
episode because usually the doctor ends
up there interacts you know the
companion they they get a real sense of
setting and it's not just about the
people here because location-wise the
doctor keeps going back and forth
between where renette is in France and
the spaceship in the future we don't get
that sense of time and place as much but
we do get a really strong sense of her
and we do get just fantastic character
work especially between the doctor and
her but also um Rose and Mickey have
some decent stuff as well this is uh a
fun episode I in many ways I I do while
I do like it a fair bit I don't always
think of it it doesn't always jump to
the front of my mind when I think about
mfet episodes that I really enjoy but
this every time I go back and rewatch
I'm like yeah this is good that is good
stuff and it
is number
five Demons of the Punjab now we get to
get back into something that gives a
really strong I feel look at an event
and a moment and a time and the people
who had to live through through it this
I think is one of the better episodes
well actually probably one of the best
episodes of the jod Whitaker Chris chel
era of Doctor Who and speaking as
someone who was raised in the US I did
not know nearly as much about the
partition of India as I honestly should
and I appreciate one doctor who gives an
examination of aspects of history that I
am less likely to be aware of and
especially when they don't feel like
window dressing when it feels like an
actual examination of that not just a
way to drop a bunch of Wikipedia level
historical information on me which some
of the chibal era historicals really
really really felt like but this one
this is focused on the people and it's
dealing with a real life horrible thing
that happened but focusing on
individuals who feel well-developed and
feel very very genuine and very of the
time in place they had to live through
this this was the experience that they
had no choice but to have shaped their
lives and in some cases end their lives
I think this tackles a very difficult
topic historical topic very very well
and in a way that is touching moving and
frankly pretty beautiful I'd actually
say that the aliens might might not even
need to be there at all this is one of
those cases where like I feel like the
aliens are there out of obligation just
because it's Doctor Who but they also
don't detract and they don't derail the
way that um some aliens showing up uh
completely derailed some other
historical but we'll get to that when I
get around to the worst list this one
this one's a high
Mark number
four the empty child and the doctor
dances it's going to come up again I
count two parters as a single story this
one funny thing about this is there's so
much amazing stuff going on in this that
how well it handles its historical
setting is only at least in my mind like
the fourth or fifth best thing about
this while still doing that really
really well so there's a lot going on
here we have the introduction of Captain
Jack Harkness we have Christopher eckl
at his best delivering what is in my
opinion his best single moment in the
show just this once everybody livs we've
got a really Insidious creeping threat
that honestly shook me first time I saw
it we've got a stellar Supporting Cast
and then underpinning all that set
during the London Blitz I kind of like
how it's introduced pretty jokingly like
yeah we have heard a lot of things fall
from the sky but then to really dig in
to the nature of what this would have
been like to really give you that
Glimpse at different aspects of people
who are preparing to go out and be on
the front lines and to fight again of
people who are just trying to live of
people living on the streets people
living in their homes of people who are
trying to help but the whole thing is
such a mess where do you even start
it captures that sense of chaos of just
trying to exist when it's feels like at
least the world is determined to end
you it captures that really well through
the setting through the various
locations of the characters we get but
especially with Nancy and the other kids
you really get that sense of yeah this
isn't a life anyone any one of them
would have chosen scr around for food
but it's the best they've got the blitz
was a period of time that scarred the
land and
traumatized basically everyone who lived
through it and the sense of that is not
diminished by the fact that there's a
gas maske wearing child wandering around
converting other people to be like him
somehow that does not take away from the
overall sensation you get of time and
place that this episode brings like
there's a lot of reasons to admire this
episode and as I said I kind of rank a
number of the other things a bit higher
than its historical aspects but it's
still really good as a historical and if
I was rating it purely on favorites it
would be higher but I am trying to
factor in the historical aspect
specifically and give that more weight
than I might have if I was ranking
purely by my own enjoyment but dang this
is
[Music]
good number
three
and now but before I say what this one
is I really wanted to put this higher
cuz this episode I think is deeply
underappreciated deeply underrated and
every time I rewatch it it just gets
better this episode is so good and not
enough people rate it nearly as highly
as they should thin
ice
this is everything in one package this
is not only giving a fantastic sense of
time and place the The Ice fair or Ice
Festival I can't remember what it what
it was now but like giving you that
sense of there but also bringing up you
know the nightmare of capitalism and the
destruction it was already in the
process of enacting all over the dang
place because profit giving us that
sense of industry but also people at
this at the street level stuck under its
boot heel and giving also that sense of
it being a more diverse and in many ways
more vibrant place than is often
depicted as and in addition to having
solid historical
stuff great great character work bill
and the doctor's interaction after the
doctor fails to save a
kid Bill confronting
him about people ding in in his presence
and about whether or not he's ever
killed anyone and not letting him weasle
his way out of things there are
situations when the options available
are limited no I
asked sometimes the choices Avil that's
not what I asked is so core to their
Dynamic and their relationship and it's
so well done this episode has basically
everything I would want in a historical
episode a real strong sense of time and
place a certain level of authenticity a
certain degree of fun but also just
great character work this has all of it
and it says a lot that part of me wants
to make this number one but there's two
that I have to say like those are even
better so as much praise as I'm heaping
on this realize how good the next two
are number
two Vincent and the doctor
one of those ones that zeros in on a
specific character it's much less about
the time and the place but it's about a
specific historical
figure where it actually works for
me because it's not about a grandis him
it's not about framing him as the
greatest this or the most magnificent
that it's about showing the pain of his
Human
Experience cuz Vincent vanoff was person
who lived with a lot of
pain and a lot of it he couldn't
help and this is I think a a
gorgeous
examination of
depression of
grief of The Limited capacity by which
those of us who do not suffer from
depression but care about someone who
has it what we can do still matters even
if we can't quote unquote save them the
pile of good things speech is such a
beautiful way to
maintain hope and a sense of Beauty in
the face of something that you can't
help in terms of like you can't make it
go
away but you can still
contribute to the goodness we definitely
added to his pile of good
thanks and as I said while I feel it is
a very
sincere uh appreciation for vanoff it is
using him primarily to examine
depression as a whole so one can argue
over the fine details of how accurate is
or isn't as I said it doesn't really do
that sense of place it feels accurate to
you know to my sensibilities but that's
not really what it's doing
but what it is doing it does
so beautifully and so
powerfully I can't put it lower than
this and if this is your number
one I will not argue with
you it's not mine
[Music]
though number
one human nature and the family of
blood what's really fascinating about
this one is because the doctor as a
character is largely absent this gives
us I think the most complete look of
just life and existence in a time period
of any Doctor Who episode because Martha
has to be Undercover the doctor can't
just be swanning about and going oh look
at all this ah he doesn't even know he's
the doctor which means we get a
very gentle Al intimate look at this
time these people this life and at
varying levels the lives of the teachers
the lives of the students the lives of
the servants an examination of boys who
were being prepped to go to war not
knowing that they were going to enter
into World War I one of the most
pointless and needlessly bloody
conflicts in world history with all your
boys falling down in the mud do you
think they will thank the man who taught
them it was glorious appreciating the
tragedy of
that that
this none of this is
glorious but they were being trained to
believe that it was and confronting that
idea and showing an honesty to the
problems but also the joys and the
beauty of life and love that could be
had in this time through the character
of John Smith Joan Redfern through the
simple Act of not having the doctor
until the very end is able to do the
most with a historical setting that
feels like it is truly just being this
just is that time that place and no
other doctor who is historical that I
can think of has ever managed to pull
that off and I'm not sure any other one
could because the doctor is often
distracting and I don't even mean that
in a bad way usually the doctors
attracting in a very fun way but we
can't just exist in the historical space
with the people who are native there
because even though Martha and the
doctor technically aren't the doctor
thinks he's John Smith so he's acting
like he belongs there and Martha is
doing her best to blend in because
that's what she has to do and that is
not even getting into how good the
romance angle is and I do not like
romance and Doctor Who as a rule of
thumb but John Smith's romance with
nurse Redford is wonderful the Triumph
initially triumphant feeling when the
doctor comes back and then the horror of
realizing what he's doing to the family
of blood and how far he's prepared to go
and and just not mess around and then
that sense of loss from Joan Redford
because yes she gets to meet the doctor
but the doctor isn't
John
oh this oh this two-parter is
phenomenal just as an episode but as a
historical
it's the best one it just
is what do you think about this list
what are your picks for the top 10
historical episodes of modern dark or
you know if you want to include classic
in yours if you feel comfortable because
again I've still got too many holes for
me to incorporate that at this point but
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
is what enables me to do this as my
living and have videos out to you every
week um I have actually caught up a
little bit on work so things are now
actually viewable in advance generally
uh about a week ahead of when they
release here so consider joining the
patreon and get stuff a little early in
addition to helping me out which I
always appreciate but even if you can't
help me out that way links to other
things that I do are down in the
description like share subscribe that's
all free that does help as well but
don't worry too much about
it what I really want you to
remember no matter what time
you are in or when you are watching this
Future Past somehow tell me how you did
that what I need you to know is you are
beautiful you are
valid you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned and I'd like to thank my
highest supporting patrons Robin Moore
subin Lula goddess ala Oliver be T Rock
the thing that goes joink in the anime
Ruth solitary pictures wri bden geek
filter Linda Walters Jen ATI Kade 808
Becky Sparks filax the poodle Robin
Powell TLO Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall white bearish rosalin Bennett
pal barava jle and marij
G uh yes we do have new rats in the
house you want it we actually have two
this is brownie I couldn't get Sprite to
come out but say
hi thanks for the
[Music]
support
woo